if your goal is to not be diabetic
you need to be working with somebody who
believes you don't have to be type 2
diabetic that this was
elicited there was an onset something
happened
if the person you're working with they
don't have the same goal as you and
they're telling you in fact the opposite
thing
get somebody else we have full
permission to do that but i think a
big reason we don't do that number one
is you know this nocebo effect and
there's kind of this fear elicited
and you know we have this trust
especially in authority figures that
they have the right answer
and it can drive right past our kind of
executive function in our brain our
reasoning our ability to distinguish
between right and wrong it kind of
bypasses that
we spend more time looking for a
vacation home
than we do for our health care if your
heart is still beating
man like there's so many different
possibilities you have to explore
you need to make it a mandate to work
with somebody who has the same goal as
you